[Music]
so a number of years ago richard thaler
a terrific economist and i were talking
about public policy and also about human
behavior and the idea developed that you
can have a form of paternalism that
preserves freedom of choice so incest
first and foremost on people being able
to go their own way if they want but it
acknowledges that some of us maybe don't
know how to get where we want to go or
that some of us may be focused on today
and not next year or that some of us
might be unrealistically optimistic or
some of us might not know a whole lot
for example about health insurance or
savings plans or about how to manage our
credit card so the idea developed which
wouldn't have sold any books but we use
it anyway called libertarian paternalism
and it we change that to a simpler form
nudge and the idea behind the
libertarian paternalism or nudge is that
you have things that are like a GPS
device so a GPS device is a form of
libertarian paternalism if you don't
like the instructions you're getting
from the little voice that's coming in
your car you can say I want the scenic
route or my prefer a direction which is
more familiar to me and I know better
than you do given what I care about
but it's steering you in a direction
which it has information suggesting is
the best way to get you where you want
to go now we can all use a GPS device in
a lot of places and this is the idea of
libertarian paternalism so if you get a
credit card bill and it has some
information about what happens if you
don't pay the full amount meaning you're
gonna start getting charged interest or
if it has information that tells you
something about the cost of late fees
that is like a GPS device in the sense
that it doesn't force you to do anything
but it tells you a little bit
how to get to what is probably your
preferred destination which is saving
money you might have also a warning on a
cigarette package or warning on
medicines and those things are Liberty
preserving because you can do whatever
you want really but it is steering you
like a GPS device in one direction
rather than another some of the most
powerful forms of libertarian
paternalism which in a way are changing
the world are using automatic enrollment
in something so that if people don't
want the thing they have to opt out
rather than saying opt in if you do want
the thing and one that's really taken
off all over the world is automatic
enrollment and savings plans the idea is
that once you are working in many places
you're just in a savings plan if you
don't want to be you can opt out but the
result of automatic enrollment has been
to increase massively participation
rates and savings plans while preserving
freedom of choice and that's going to
mean that people over the world are
going to have more comfortable
retirements now the idea of more
comfortable retirements is important it
may not be the sort of thing that gets
people's juices flowing but when I
worked in the White House between 2009
and 2012 we thought a lot about this
about things that could help people
while preserving their freedom of choice
and one little example does get at least
my juices flowing which is there is a
program to allow poor kids to have free
school lunches and breakfasts and it's
something that isn't politically
inflamed
everyone thinks if you're below a
certain threshold of poverty you should
get a nutritious meal at school and it's
it's free you got it but a lot of kids
haven't signed up maybe because the
parents are scared if they get some form
from the government maybe because of the
form from the government is kind of
daunting and complicated maybe because
the parents are busy and focused on
other things rather than some
bureaucratic note from the Department of
Agriculture of the local school so what
we did is basically just shifted the
default if the locality knows that
you're eligible for the meal you
getting the meal if you don't want to be
in the program you can opt out but
you're automatically in and at last
count that meant that means that about
11 million kids in the United States are
getting school meals for free to which
they're entitled and 11 million is a
statistic but if you think of some small
fraction of those kids you know ages 6 7
8 9 and imagine them having something
that's got to produce no hunger and
nutrition that's a small intervention
that is having a real impact okay so one
of the exciting things about the last
ten years is that the interest in
libertarian paternalism or nudging has
been intense and strong and it's cut
across partisan lines so when I worked
in the White House there were a number
of things I worked on that Democrats
liked and Republicans not so much
climate change regulation Republicans
were not that excited about it and
President Trump not so excited about it
and Democrats were approving but
libertarian paternalism we didn't use
the name but things like information
disclosure about credit cards
information disclosure about mortgages
automatic enrollment in Savings Plans
simplification of forms which is a way
of preserving Liberty but ensuring that
people aren't just drowning in
complexity which prevents them from
taking advantage of something all of
these things were able to attract
bipartisan enthusiasm so Americans don't
like their freedom being entry intruded
on they don't like the idea of public
officials saying you know we know better
than you do
but so long as their freedom to go their
own way is maintained they are good with
things like warnings reminders
information switching the default rule
you can imagine some examples of those
that would get people's hackles up but
generally and this is the kind of excite
I think of the era were in these ideas
informed by behavioral science four
decades of testing are changing people's
lives saving in some cases literally
billions of dollars saving in other
cases a significant number of lives per
year these are things that don't really
get the I think salutary American
antipathy to mandates from
self-appointed in some cases elite and
in other cases an elected elite the
opposition to mandates does not apply to
libertarian paternalism at least so long
as the word libertarian doesn't merely
have too many syllables to be kind of
the friendliest word but it's at least
so long as it really means freedom then
we're then we're doing something that's
compatible with American culture
[Music]